it's the final chapter the final
countdown the last leg of the dang
compression quest congratulations if you
made it this far yeah thanks for joining
us we will we'll see if we can we'll see
if we can jam on ahead and and get out
of ruts and see a brighter tomorrow day
you know play along at home you know
keep it keep a scorecard see if you can
get undepressed while we tried to get
under press yeah maybe you will make
better decisions than we did hey
possible you never know although I mean
we are recording this in hindsight so we
do know and we're just going along with
the illusion that this is alive yeah
we're bending space and time bending
space and time because you don't know
when we recorded this we could have
recorded this piece first we actually
recorded this after you listen to it
yeah we recorded this after you listen
to it but that was also like six weeks
ago yeah so um we are everything
everywhere all the time so dank pression
quest the final round get ready get
right to fight to fight your inner
demons and existential self get ready to
punish to punish the low self-worth
right out of you get ready for a mom to
still not understand I'm just doesn't
get it it's like that song from the
eighties parents just don't understand
him yeah that was that song about
depression I don't think so it was like
everything is like a 90s rap or
something here in a dress I don't know
dank freshman class ding crushed glass
you sit down to your computer to blow
off some steam but are surprised to find
your thoughts drifting to your long
neglected project you talk yourself into
opening it up and taking a look at it
for the first time and what must be
weeks for whatever reason your anger
that you've been feeling towards your
day job seems to have converted to pure
passion as you seem to be overflowing
with ideas tonight oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude
for
shadowing it's as if you've got a build
up of ideas that just haven't gotten out
and now you're in the zone while you
don't get an unnatural amount of work
done you do work for a solid couple of
hours and it feels really great what's
more you share some stuff across your
social media networks and you receive
quite a bit of positive feedback which
makes you feel great what is our project
when you cook top when you go to bed at
night you tell yourself that your job
Mase up but at least you've got
something you really care about that you
can put effort into and feel really good
about and feel really good about
yourself in fact as you're falling
asleep you can barely even remember your
work day whoa the statuses have changed
you're moderately depressed you find it
hard to focus on anything because you
get physically and mentally exhausted
very quickly you are in therapy with a
good counselor you're doing cognitive
behavioral therapy techniques and they
are starting to help oh [ __ ] your
medication is helping to keep the edge
off and keep some of the darker and more
negative feedback loops from being as
prevalent oh [ __ ] dude it's a little
past 288 p.m. on a tuesday now and not
on a Tuesday you're at your computer
frustration levels pinked rubbing your
eyes and sighing heavily you're working
on a project from your job that has you
stretch to wits and trying to meet a
looming deadline and as it looks closer
and closer you're seriously doubting
your ability to get it done you've
dragged you've been driving your feet a
little at work due to your complete lack
of energy lately in spite of wanting to
do a good job you finding your feet at
work despite your gigantic feet you find
yourself unable to push past it and feel
horribly useless for it you slide your
hands off of your face to look at your
screen as it beeps at you attic hey are
you there I really need to talk to
someone about something oh [ __ ] you feel
like you're getting nowhere with your
current task and could probably use a
break however you know that you have a
history of game distracted and then
losing motivation to pick something back
up again afterwards what do you do oh
man you don't multitask number two is
tell attic you're busy number three is
trying to regain your focus don't answer
number fours answer attic I would answer
I would answer at it because you know
it's like addict was there for us yeah
one you know this this prompt seems you
know serious enough yeah addict seems
like they're in a serious plays like bro
what you up to it's like hey yo do come
outside oh yeah y'all do yeah I got a
little stereo speaker I gotta sell out
of much room oh I want to do the thing
words like a show like her like a sketch
or something words like to do just on
the phone like look kind of glazed eyes
at each other ones in the car and the
other ones in his in his room and
they're just talking to each other one
dude is like they do a vehicle on sad
and the other dude is like saying not do
you come in and the first is I not do
you come outside not do you come inside
and just do that for like an hour of
them going back and forth there's a joke
not an hour not not not quite like that
but there's a joke and they came
together I was watching earlier were
Paul Rudd's having a shitty day and he
goes into this bar and the bartender
says you look like you could use a drink
Paul Rudd says tell me about it he goes
well you know you came in here you know
Shelley had a bad day and then Paul
grego's you'd say that again it's like
why you came in here just look if i get
a bad day then goes tell me about it and
then it's not this loop and let it go on
a couple not none it's probably not as
long as it felt but they let that loop
go hun and then finally cuts to like
Bill Hader or somebody being like okay
we get it was this some they came
together yeah okay guys you know silly
absurd so it's like Paul Rudd is Paul
Rudd is just saying every Lake throw
away of affirmation line of
I've had a shitty day and then okay yeah
that's funny we're going to answer attic
we're gonna answer it here's the thing
there seems to be a pattern where the
the answers are listed in order from
more healthy to least healthy like the
healthiest answer always feels like it's
on top as cross out the second more most
functioning answers 2 and 3 and by the
time you get to four or five and six is
like the least functioning human being
answer all those yeah so attic answer
attic is number four of four so in this
scenario it's indicated as being not the
best option well because maybe we might
spend the next several hours
commiserating you know yeah so you're
feeling like you've hit a brick wall
with your tasks so when I take a break
and help out a friend you hey what's up
attic oh good you're there um I just
found out I got cheated on I don't know
what to do now that's horrible the two
of you talked for a long time and you
lend a shoulder to your friend you give
him space to ran to cry and most
importantly to be able to voice his
inner turmoil you give him your full
attention and talking through what his
options are for what he does next you
keep him from doing something rash and
the two of you decide it's best for him
sleep on it before doing anything
exhausted he departs for bed and thanks
you for being there to talk with him as
you closed the IM window you feel
horribly sorry for your friend but happy
that you were able to help it serves as
a tangible reminder to you that you're
capable of being useful to someone
instead of solely being a mess that
needs everyone else's help this was
healthy yeah we're a slightly empowered
just was healthy no to suit you boot up
your work project to find that you're
suddenly able to get some solid progress
done on it that night oh [ __ ]
accomplishment breeds further
accomplishment hey it's a sunny Saturday
afternoon you're in deep thought on the
way home from therapy however you notice
this time that you're not in the same
negative feedback loops you
really get trapped in when being this
introspective you realize that although
you still have your bad days your lows
aren't quite as low as they used to be
your antidepressants bottle rolls across
your dashboard as you take a left turn
you've been on this medication for quite
a while now after a period of trying a
few different kinds though you still
have minor side effects they've overall
become an unnoticed part of your life
you feel as though your life has
generally changed for the better
recently and you begin to wonder if you
need them anymore you don't feel as much
despair or hopelessness and you hate
yourself a lot less these days maybe
it's time to stop taking an easy thing I
seemed to not really need them anymore
what do you do continue taking your
medication go off your meds don't go off
your [ __ ] meds don't go off your meds
although I wish there was like a third
option which would be like talk to your
therapist yes yes I could discuss your
discuss with your therapist adjusting
your dosage and maybe weaning or
whatever goes like [ __ ] you
don't want you don't want withdrawals
yeah you don't want to just be like yeah
I'm good yeah all these all this you
know surplus these you know brain
chemicals I've built up in my brain like
I'm just gonna stop doing that now yeah
I dramatically shifted my brains
chemistry i'm just gonna dramatically
shift it again yeah i'm just
automatically no gradual taper off or
anything oh not yet let's continue
continue taking Frank come on come on
you have the realization that you can't
be sure if it's a general life change
that's making you feel better or if it's
just a sign that the medication is
working you decide against discontinuing
your meds it's not really a lesson you'd
like to learn the hard way and the side
effects of this particular kind are
negligible the next time you see dr.
Melville you tell her about this she
informs you that this is a common train
of thought that people who have begun
using medication to help them manage a
depression experience and that you've
managed to dodge a bullet because it
generally ends poorly what I say well
she also asks you to talk to her first
before making any decisions about your
medication in the future what have we
say next because that's yeah next throw
it with some more life events it's yet
another sleepless Thursday night you're
Alex's apartment wide awake in bed as
she's sleeping peacefully beside you to
show off did you guys which show off
that she's able to sleep peacefully
exactly look look at you sleep in peace
[ __ ] this I'm over here looking at you
when I could be asleep too she fell
asleep hours ago and you've been loud
works ago hours ago and you've been
laying here unable to shut your brain up
long enough to fall asleep you've added
the feelings of insecurity about your
relationship to the rest of the noise in
your head keeping you up tonight it was
kind of a tense night between the two of
you you arrived after a stressful day at
work and as you made dinner together you
barely said a word ooh you were stuck in
your own head and had a hard time really
being present with her as your thoughts
turn to all the ways you feel like
you're deficient at being a good person
beating yourself up mentally for each
one she told you she could tell you were
in quote-unquote one of your moods and
lady I have a mental illness maybe we're
not very open with you maybe she doesn't
know anything yeah we have we talked to
Alex about the fact that were diagnosed
with depression I feel like we wouldn't
have I mean she's willing she seems very
willing to be there and to support us
yeah and she said she wouldn't push you
but miss talking to you
is the two of you sat on the couch
together you wanted to tell her how much
you love her but you couldn't make the
words come out right and ended up
sounding defensive instead love you shut
up go my back mom as you lay there next
to her now you trace your fingers across
her arm just lightly enough not to not
wake her you still haven't explained
your depression to her what or how you
started seeing a therapist this is bad
oh so you started seeing a therapist or
that you've been taking medication and
it's starting to feel more and more like
a secret you're keeping instead of
something she simply doesn't know about
yet oh god no it's becoming more and
more apparent that it's impacting your
relationship with her and you feel
guilty about this however you're also
terrified that if she knew exactly how
[ __ ] up you are that she would leave
you you already worried that she's only
with you because she doesn't realize how
terrible the person you are yet and
you're afraid that this would be the
final thing to expose you she stirs in
her sleep and squints as she opens her
eyes with the confusion that comes with
waking up she asks if you're awake and
then if everything's okay what do you do
number one not number one open up to her
with ease of course not nothing is easy
nothing number two tell her about your
situation number three tell her it's
nothing and that she should go back to
sleep here's the problem uh we should do
number two like tomorrow yeah we should
do number two tomorrow we shouldn't do
number two like like day morning for I
am but check it out though I've I've
been i die i was diagnosed with clinical
depression several months ago and I've
been seeing a therapist and taking meds
in secret that's see that would be sooo
weird thing responding to the one hand
it's like good morning I have a mental
illness and I didn't tell you well yeah
it's like then you have to have like
three reactions all at one time where
it's like oh god I'm concerned for you
oh
glad you've sought help how could you
keep this from me yeah yeah yeah um whoa
I mean I feel like telling her about our
situation is ultimately the best idea
but now is not the best time it's it's a
good time in like movie world yeah words
like you know you your tents and your
head is spinning about this conversation
about this this topic she wakes up and
then you just come cleaning this big
dramatic gesture man but it's like early
in the morning and she's tired and
bleary eyed isn't a good time for this
but you know I guess I cuz I don't know
what they're gonna give us later I guess
anything that gets us you know more
openness probably does yeah tell her
about your situation you feel like a
jerk for accidentally waking her up but
you're afraid if you put this off any
longer you won't find the strength to
tell her everything later no actually
everything isn't okay can I tell you
something something important Alex it's
up rubbing the sleep out of her eyes for
the rest of the night you lay side by
side holding hands as you tell her
everything you tell her how it it's more
than just feeling sad sometimes I feel
trapped by your own mind sometimes how
sometimes you feel nothing at all and
how you can't shake it off you tell her
how you started going to therapy how you
feel embarrassed by it and how it's
working out for you she listens the
entire time occasionally asking
questions about how this or that works
we're asking you to explain something
further she squeezes your hand and tells
you she understands and that she's sad
you didn't tell her sooner after laying
silent for a moment the weight of what
you did hits you you desperately want
her to say something to tell you how
she's feeling about all of this but you
too afraid of what the answer would be
to ask you start convincing yourself
that now she knows everything she's
going to leave there's no way someone
could deal with how you really are so
how can I help what do you need me to do
she
asks you think for a second and the
answer you come up with fills you with
despair I honestly don't know I wish I
knew how to fix this but I don't know
that you can do anything I think it's
something I just have to live with she
looks at you with sad eyes before
kissing you on the forehead then I'll
live with it with you Oh alex is to Bev
that's I'm like that's really sweet but
that's way too perfect of a wine dude no
dude alex is just a class act I don't
know how you could possibly love me she
rolls over wraps her arms around your
neck settling her head on top of yours
you don't need to just know that I do
dude alex got the lines you are
definitely still depressed but things
are getting better whatever you're doing
seems to be working you really feel like
you're taking steps to effect positive
change in your life you now seem to
enjoy seeing your therapist between
giving you a chance to talk things out
in the cbts technique she shares with
you you find your sessions extremely
helpful you have been taking your
medication regularly and while you were
skeptical at first it's hard to argue
with the fact that you're feeling better
than you have in a long time boom damn
net digs you have this the Polaroid of
this one starts with Netflix this one
starts with my Netflix Polaroid it's a
friday night in your lay across your bed
feeling pathetic what the [ __ ] dude we
just had a breakthrough just aha Bob as
you were leaving work tonight a group of
coworkers asked if you want to join them
for drinks feeling antisocial and put on
the spot you declined you have a habit
of doing this you're often so convinced
that you're weird and terrible and then
any invitation to hang out when a
disappointment for those inviting you
you never feel like you know how to act
in group settings and you feel like a
total creep since it seems to come some
naturally to anyone who isn't you you
find yourself petrified of breaking some
unknown social rule that you don't go
out often now however you find yourself
alone at home your brain has begun
telling you how pathetic and sad you are
for being unable to just be
normal person and go out with nice
people you can't figure out why you
can't just go out and meet people and
enjoy yourself at the same time you're
also feeling like no one would possibly
want to hang out with you if would know
no one would want to hang out if they
really knew you because you're dull and
weird anyway you try your typical
strategy and boot up Netflix to distract
yourself from these feelings but
frustration with yourself builds and you
realize do you have to do something else
with your night anything else to make
your to take your mind enough of how
awful and lonely you feel right now what
do you do that's not number one which is
get over it and go out to the bar where
your co-workers or hanging out anyway
number two you could see if addict is
online oh man 3 call Alex for drink huh
drink 5-ranked go outside go out
somewhere alone six play with your cat
um don't drink yeah don't drink because
no six play with you cat I hope we've
been feeding it no cuz it's like oh yeah
I have a cat walks into a room corpse
that's a sinister we would that would
[ __ ] us up yeah um how does it go Alex
yeah quahogs is a good idea cuz like
seeing if addict is online you don't
want to maybe start like a commiseration
party yeah it's also past a certain
point it's past a certain point I don't
think anyone can deal with just like
everyone's a little bit's it comes to
the stigma of I spend all night just
talking to people on the internet that
are my internet friends yeah it blows
but it's like you know you get to sucked
into it you can't help but go down that
rabbit hole of thought going on
somewhere alone can be nice but I feel
like here would just lead to more while
yeah going if you go out somewhere alone
it's like it can be going out somewhere
alone can be like you know mine clearing
and kind of fun but other times the
sense of being alone in a in the outside
world where everything is bustling with
activity you end up feeling like a dude
in an Edward Hopper painting yeah
exactly you end up feeling like oh like
a morose Nighthawks character hey call
Alex or play with your cat I would say
call Alex yeah because the cat loves you
but Alex can talk to you yeah well how
do we know they can't talk what if
that's a talking cat maybe that's your
project your project your project is
making your cat talk yes exact but no
because it involves a computer so it's
on the computer and you post on social
media so well yeah it's a program for
the communication device it allows your
cat to talk if you were developing a
communication device to make cats talk
like you wouldn't be a depressed person
with the menial job you would have
government grants maybe you're just a
prodigy and you think you're too shitty
to let anybody know that but you posted
on social media that would have gone
viral and you'd be famous like within a
week maybe the product is that being
funny the project is not making the cat
talk it could but it's not this is
depression quest that depressed person
who's making a cat talk quest hey it's
nice fiction this isn't this isn't eric
robertson a talking depressed cat it's
it's science fiction okay because
depression is science and this is a
fictional story we're gonna call out
looks okay we're good guys you got
dangerously close to play another cat oh
we're gonna call but the cliq didn't
happen all right you dial alex's phone
number figuring that if you could spend
some time with her instead of being
cooped up in your apartment alone you
might feel less isolated phone rings a
handful of times before going to
voicemail
you know it's not uncommon for her to be
out with her friends at this hour you
leave a voicemail but end up calling
again 15 minutes later still no response
you imagine Alex out with her friends
much like you would be tonight if you
weren't so horrible at social know your
mind wanders and you start to wonder who
she's with and Oh God if she's meeting
someone tonight who she'd rather be with
someone who is able to go to parties
like this with her instead of sitting at
home feeling sorry for themselves oh god
why didn't she invite you have you just
sent no one too many times how many
other fridays have you unknowingly
missed he who began to think that maybe
it would be better if she met someone
tonight she's a wonderful woman and you
feel like a constant joy kill on nights
like mon Dieu why can't you just be
normally we should've played the [ __ ]
cat I'm sorry the next morning Alex
calls you back she tells you that she
left her phone in class and spent a
boring night in her apartment to you
feel horribly embarrassed about how
emotionally you'd gotten over mistaken
assumptions the night before mm-hmm well
that was a shitty night it was a shitty
night but at least it wound up semi
uneventful yeah it's a cold Saturday
afternoon BRR you just arrived at Alex's
apartment and you're happy to finally
see her after a week of absence dude
your schedules not lining up due to work
in school due to you have a job in Jesus
student do too she goes to college you
hug her in the doorway but she breaks
away sooner than normal and sits down on
the couch as you take off your sneakers
and lay them in the usual place I don't
wear sneakers right next to hers but
there was something I was hoping we
could talk about actually Oh God you
instantly worried that you're being
blindsided by a breakup conversation see
a line like that I instantly know okay
you're not yeah usually worried that
you're being blindsided by a breakup
conversation due to the sudden shift in
tone but you quickly smiles and puts you
at ease once she sees all the color
leave your face
it's nothing bad I promise with that she
leads you over to the couch and sits you
on the other end of it facing you I got
a cat no ID so I hope this doesn't freak
you out and I feel like things are going
too fast and if you feel like things are
going too fast just tell me she talks
faster than usual and fidgets we seen
have a lot of weeks like this and they
really suck I was thinking that ask
since things are so strong with us what
are your thoughts on maybe moving in
together it takes a few seconds to sink
in and leaves you a bit shocked when it
does your words you want to spend less
time with you not more do you want to
you ask well yeah I do I mean we'd have
to sort out logistics and everything but
those are all things we can take care of
you start to walk through the steps of
imagining the two of you living together
you love the thought of being able to
wake up next door every day and sing her
so often however the more you pictured
the more few concerns become apparent
there are things she isn't there things
she is insulated from like the days you
don't feel like you can even get out of
bed the nice new medication keeps you
from being able to sleep all of those
moments you're stuck staring at the wall
completely out of energy and feeling
nothing how would she handle that how
quickly would she want to get away so
she starts what do you think number one
is not on the table taking relationship
to the next step with ease move in
together yeah to tiller you 12 but have
concerns and discuss them honestly
number 22 a second too there's some
typos here and there I've tripped over a
couple of tell her you don't think it's
a good idea for you right now three
decide to move in regardless of your
worries it's add to the first two maybe
that's why maybe that's what gamergate
is all about people are angry that of
the occasional typos in this game huh
Steven Klein was trying to read and was
rudely interrupted by a human error this
is why we need ethics in games
journalism for repeated numbers
um let's see I mean top one tell her you
wanted to but have concerns and discuss
them honestly to a yeah honesty seems to
be the best policy being open and frank
with your support network yada yada yada
so on and so forth also you know if you
know Alex is chill it may help to have
somebody who's around you being a sub I
mean again sucks to be like using your
partner's medication but it could be
helpful just in general to have somebody
who cares about you in close proximity
well yeah and like easily accessible
benevolent human contact you know like
yeah cuz like you live alone you don't
even have a roommate except that cat
yeah and you haven't even perfected the
talking the software yeah yeah you put
the talking cat dude this is gonna be
your breakthrough master project you
were really worried that if Alex were to
live with you she wouldn't be able to
deal with your days of being unable to
get out of bed or nights where you can
do nothing but stare at the wall and
panic even though you've discussed your
situation with are you still fear that
she doesn't realize the depth of how bad
it gets it's one thing for you to detail
how you feel sometimes and for her to
see it pop up occasionally it's an
entirely different situation for it to
be something she has to live with
alongside you well I'd like to but I
think it's best if we talk about it more
before committing to a decision though
she seems a little defeated you make it
clear that you're not making excuses and
actually mean that you want to talk you
reiterate a lot of what you told Alex
that night and although she gets a
little defensive and tells you that she
knows all of that already she confirms
that she is willing to help you sort
through your issues I feel like you
forget i love you sometimes i know that
there will be bad days and I'd rather
try to work through them with you we can
figure all this out together her words
way you and you can't help but hold her
close to you
oh wait wait you are doing well you may
still have your bad days but you now
have effective ways to deal with them
and you don't get nearly as low as you
used to or for as long you still visit
your therapist and even she has remarked
on how much more alive you seemed lately
you are taking your medication regularly
and are pleased at how well it seems to
be working I'd add me that sounds good
I'm a little afraid that tomorrow is
gonna be a terrible day for some yeah so
we're doing like this is our peak so far
we're getting we're getting there man
we're starting to live the dream yeah
like either next next page is gonna be
you finish your project it's amazing you
want a Pulitzer those cats can talk to
each other and you you're now wealthy
and rich and our beloved by everyone
around you accept your yeah except your
monsters your mom doesn't understand it
doesn't understand and wishes you muy
mal koala either that or it's like it's
either going to just you know or it's
gonna be like Oh today's today sucked
yeah is it it's a the spooky Wednesday
more [ __ ] with shitty at work it's
December Christmas
it's December and you've returned to I
don't know I did the job on it's
December and you've returned to your
parents house too so I'm right the
holidays with your family with the
American people uh out the living room
window you can see a gentle flurry of
snow drifting down to meet the pristine
blanket of white from yesterday's
unexpected Christmas Eve snowfall on
your scrap beds and you quietly left
yourself at how incredibly cliche it
seems Oh [ __ ] still as you sit down
to dinner you can't help but notice
being surrounded by family and the
overly kitschy atmosphere your mom's
decorations have created have actually
made you feel relaxed and almost
comfortable your mom is running around
frantically checking the oven and the
stockings and just generally trying to
family time it up while your dad sits
the head of the table drinking a beer
and love your brother Malcolm his wife
Karen is there to whom you've always
gotten along well with and your parents
even agreed to let you bring your kitten
along who can now talk because your
project was awesome they've let you
bring your kidding along she's been
darting in and out of people's legs and
hopping into laps all night as you
thoughtfully munch away at your turkey
listening to the conversations around
you your thoughts drift back over the
last few months you think about how hard
things had gotten replaying over in your
head some of the worst as well as some
of your best memories it seems like all
these things just came to a head over
the past few months with a sudden flurry
of relationship turmoil and professional
anxiety social stress and above all an
omnipresent sense of weight that it
seems you have just recently become
aware of your drawn out of your reverie
by your dad's familiar booming laugh is
so cheesy comment Malcolm made seems to
have hit its mark sitting at the table
you're suddenly immensely glad for the
chance to be able to ignore everything
for an evening
not have to struggle trying to explain
yourself for once fortunately everyone
seems to be content with laughing at
each other's jokes and discussing what's
more smoky and for a while you think
you'll be able to get through dinner
without any embarrassing personal
intrusions but no sooner did the thought
cross your mind then the table
conversation trickles off leaving a
slightly awkward silence to descend upon
the dinner so how are you doing these
days your mom asks you pointedly it's
such a simple question and one that you
seem to have to answer countless times
recently you take a moment to collect
your thoughts then looking up and take a
deep breath well cuts of credits rap
song don't you dare to do don't don't
don't don't don't do you never really
thought of yourself as a fighter and
even to say it now sounds hokey it's
alarms for getting this is weak arm
spaghetti but looking back on the past
few months to where you are now it
really does feel like you've endured an
immense struggle and you look at where
you are now with the sense of something
that isn't quite pride you still hate
your job and find it unpleasant but
you're surprised to find that going to
work every day is no longer a monumental
challenge you started adopting some
clever techniques like taking short
two-minute breaks every hour to break up
the monotony and now you now view your
job is just eight short hours of your
day a compartmentalization technique dr.
Melville told you about that you found
actually works quite well you know this
job isn't what you want to do for the
rest of your life and you start actively
looking for other positions even
attending a couple of preliminary
interviews what you started making
effort to go out with your friends more
while the social steen still makes you
very uncomfortable sometimes you're more
and more able to let yourself just enjoy
the company of your friends in fact your
relationship with many of them has
increased over the past little while you
still definitely have days where you
flake out or don't feel up to hanging
out but for the most
hurt your friends are understanding and
appreciated communication by far the
biggest change you noticed in your life
has been in your relationship without
you were terrified of taking of talking
to her about everything at first but
looking back you feel like it's only
strengthen your relationship she was
always supportive of you emotionally but
lately the two of you have been even
more in sync and it's really starting to
feel like you're building a life
together and [ __ ] it it seems it even
seems like the two of you have been
making a more concerted effort to sync
up your schedules that have been
spending more and more of your downtime
with each other pretty soon you think
moving in together and maybe a very real
possibility dr. Melville has commented
on how well you seem to be doing and
whether a result of the therapy the
medication are both you can't help but
agree with all that seen aims to have
improved with all that seems to have
improved recently it's sometimes
difficult for you to think about the
fact that you still have bad days
sometimes even really bad days they
serve as a stark reminder of the fact
that this will be something you likely
have to deal with for the rest of your
life depression is a battle and though
you're certainly ahead in the fight you
know the battle isn't ever going to be
over sometimes even Alice can tell when
things are going rough despite your best
efforts to the contrary while you know
that your depression can never be cured
you have a very strong support network
in your friends and even Malcolm and
armed with a newfound confidence in your
friends and family you accept that
though the road maybe rocky it's at very
least not solitary you meet your mom's
gauged from across the table and muster
up a smile I'm good mom you tell her she
says nothing but you can feel her smile
from across the room oh [ __ ] epilogue
epipen we really want to thank you for
taking the time to play depression quest
we realize it may not be the most
enjoyable game you've ever played or
even the easiest and we sincerely
appreciate your involvement if you would
like to contribute to the developers
into the National Suicide Prevention
lifeline please click this link to do so
like depression stuff depression quest
does not have an end really there is no
neat resolution to
and it was important to us the
depression quest the depression quest
own resolution reflect that instead of a
tidy ending we want to just provide a
series of outlooks to take moving
forward after all that's all we can
really do with depression just keep
moving forward and at the end of the day
it's our outlook and our support from
people just like you that makes all the
difference in the world thanks again hot
damn we beat depression impression now
we'll never be sad again oh [ __ ] except
no and depression is you just kind of
learned to live with it it's pretty much
exactly what we just ignored exactly
what should just say oh we got too
excited about having to feed a
depression yeah um our mom doesn't
understand but she gets it mom mom
understands as much as she needs to that
we we I yeah I'm good mom that is
interesting man's I wonder if there are
different out like I wonder who you want
to get the bad end well yeah it's like
what if you you know if you're answering
questions honestly or you know I mean
not that we didn't I feel like we
answered a lot of reasons I like to
think I mean I'm pretty sure there isn't
like a root of playing depression quest
that ends with you like well you [ __ ]
up and succumb to your illness now
there's nothing left but suicide it's a
cold winter day and you're lying in a
gutter with a needle sticking like it's
like now you're an alcoholic too yeah
your depression led you here you're an
alcoholic and a heroin addict you're up
you're on a 5150 except that's only in
California well yeah like I I don't
think it would end of that terribly but
yeah I wonder I feel like wonder what
the design is cuz like you know yes how
I just each track get here's my
assumption um I figure no matter how I
feel like
my assumption is if you keep playing the
game and you keep on having bad days and
backsliding and not managing yourself
and and getting really bad either
there's a slide that's like yeah things
just kind of don't work out for you and
you gotta fight your way through it some
other way and there's a difference send
off entirely or it just kind of ropes
you around and loops you to a place
where you find some coping mechanism
yeah or or yeah yeah you just kind of
keep trudging forward again I think at
some points like if you refuse therapy I
feel like it would probably be I assume
there will be slides out something
happens where you have to you can't the
game kind of slides you into therapy
like someone someone inputs mean
intervenes or puts her foot down yeah
good you know maybe your maybe you know
you haven't some kind of horrible
episode and you get committed for a
weekend or something yeah i mean i don't
know maybe yeah I'm trying to imagine
like how the game would handle you know
going on a going on an involuntary hold
all right we're going through it again
if this time we got to pick all the
worst answers all the all the absolute
self loathing totally totally beyond
help symptomatic I'm gonna talk so hard
to addict yeah we're gonna be such dicks
to attic we're going to just we're just
going to just drop contact with Alex
[ __ ] the cat yeah no cat no Alex no
addict we're just gonna sit around with
mom and Malcolm the worst people for us
and bring them with us to work yeah is
mom and Malcolm and work all day but
even Malcolm becomes cool f yeah just
mom and work mom and everywhere the
worst versus depression cuz every day is
bring your mom to work day she means
well it just doesn't get your work
that's hard mode of depression quest
hard mode for depression quest is bring
your mom too
work day oh man I mean well that's in
the dlc see how unlocked expert mode can
you play with different skins can you
like customize your character customize
you care oh that would be horrible is
like you had to play Webbie hormones
like you play different versions of
depression quest words like guess what
you don't have white privilege now oh
hey that would be interesting that I'm
you know to really diversify it like all
this version of depression quest you're
a woman then this person just press
requests you know your your I feel like
this version of depression quest you
could be a gay woman there's not enough
to be a game there's nothing there's not
enough to specify it's like Alex as a
woman and you must be a man well yeah
and and and you know then that would be
easier ground for your mom not to
understand and for me welcome to be
surprisingly cool yeah you know cuz like
you are you're the one gay you're the
one gay kid hmm hmm sorry that was a
yarn for are you playing at home you're
tired are you depressed no I'm walk kind
of but listen no not in this context I
just been up for a while okay well we
did it we did it man we will play
depression quest and we didn't have to
get gamers or anything yeah whatever the
[ __ ] that hashtag is hey man that was
interesting like I did enjoy this and
and you know speaking as a you know as a
vaguely functioning you know semi
depressive person you know a lot of
these things hit home and like these a
lot of decisions I've had to weigh yeah
and you know a lot of situations you
know maybe not in in some of the like
character specifics but you know a lot
of these types of situations ring true
and head home so it's actually rather
constructive you know dude especially
checking in you know and where you're at
in life you know I gotta say I mean it's
interesting because I'm imagining what
it would be like to play this game works
like you have the uphill battle of say a
far I mean I granted I maybe this is
like an idealized version of the
Canadian healthcare system maybe there's
more inconvenience for to get average
person in Canada too but just imagine
for a moment being like having to play
through depression quest but on top of
it you have to fight you have to fight
to have the motivation to find a
therapist and go through all the
inconvenience and all of the brick walls
and like manage you with your insurance
and like have to go back and be like oh
no they're not going to pay for this
many sessions unless I have a diagnosis
and I need you to give me the diagnosis
and then a blood or depression quest but
but for countries that aren't very good
with you know mental health you they are
all being oh yeah or like what you
described of or we described with the
you know with your buddy words like you
know the work just changed to his
insurance provider out of nowhere yeah
and so he has to start right one with a
totally different totally different
therapist network sucks even yeah it's
like oh you have a therapist and the
therapist is working out for you but you
have to go to a psychiatrist now and
your therapist isn't a psychiatrist good
luck [ __ ] good luck sad [ __ ] yeah
sorry you're being sad and all hey man
you want pills to fix your sad too bad
too bad on the SAB pills yeah hey man I
mean you know maybe depression quest to
yeah you know or it's like oh you're one
of those rare people were the inactive
ingredients actually change a lot so you
have to specifically buy the expensive
as brand name drugs because the generic
isn't gonna work for you oh oh I didn't
even know that was the thing until not
long ago yeah cuz there's so much of
that you know there's so much sort of
like for most people like
doesn't matter but for enough people it
matters who doesn't matter hard yeah
yeah it matters like a [ __ ]
mental illness what I was like mental
illness whoo hey man we need it we need
to maybe you know do better at least in
America with just like how we handle and
you know approach and treat this I feel
like depression quest is a great game
for people living with the brush and it
or depression quest is cool because it's
like if you have lived with dysthymia or
like low great depression you can kind
of see like oh yeah this hits home for
me and it's like I'm not alone and
enough people have understood the way in
which this works to represent it in a in
a game that has a systematic base to it
and everything it's also could be good
with people's like oh I have friends who
have depression I've never had it so I
don't know what it's like and then you
you know actually play the game it's
like oh yeah you feel like you feel like
the options to live a healthy life gets
struck like gets stolen from you well
yeah and sort of you know seeing all
those answers crossed out yeah I can't
choose the best idea yeah I can't choose
to live my life to the fullest because
that option has been stolen from me but
the the disease um but it's like I'm
imagining what would be like for you
know someone in the mental health world
to be to play depression quest and see
that represented to them yeah I'll be
injured I don't know husband has anybody
attacked it from that angle [ __ ] I don't
know will les call up some therapist
yeah let's call it some therapist they
won't answer because we'll get their
voicemail but if this is a psychiatric
emergency please hang up and dial 911 or
go to your nearest emergency room let's
just take this game 2 on your servers if
this is like you at rideau murders we go
into an emergency room it's like what's
wrong we need someone to play this game
and tell us about their thoughts we need
someone who preferably has studied at
least a little bit of a they can you
know your mental mental
yeah just to take a look-see and you
know speak toward the authenticity of
this experience yeah then we'll just our
luck will get like an mft or a
psychiatrist or an MD being like yeah no
this isn't how depression works at all
really this is this as your subjective
experience may feel like but this and
how the disease works and this is a
horrible thing to play if you're trying
to understand depression and then we
look like fools that would be a bummer
that would be sad I don't think that'll
be the outcome I wouldn't be down for
that at all nah dude the elephant plates
you this then uh frostbite balls no you
frostbite ball z alpha fuzzy-wuzzy other
when there was there were three yeah
there's another one what were our what
were our one episode memes yeah I mean
Frank has tubs but he's in Franco's tubs
yeah I think that was it but Franca's
tubs lives on in our hearts oh yeah he's
more he's more than a meme he's more
than a man he's a purveyor of fine
spices marinades and herb rubs how is
that not been like a Sony movie like a
sony superhero movie it's like he's more
man than me but more mean than man hey
well thick cuz when the movies are the
the second long they wanted to find out
about what would be like if Peter Parker
did the tough mudder the spartan race or
park or whatever nonsense and those
leaked emails oh yeah an EDM oh yes I am
yeah some sony exec was like kids are
into these mean things could we could we
make spider-man a meme I didn't want to
believe that emails like that could
exist just because like they did come
across little cartoony it's like you
know you gotta be out of touch
that's it's always a bad sign when
you're looking at the youth and being
like now these mean things he can Peter
Parker fight one of those hahaha then
it's like ah no no like bad news bears
like you gotta don't you got a new got
to don't you've got to don't just get
off your airplane right broken off
private jet and maybe read the internet
yeah a little bit like go ask your
nephew I don't know yeah or not just
imagining um imagining the Sony exactly
fighting depression closely these uh
these Millennials sure like thinking
about sad thing nothing they're like
existential crises and you know so i got
like oh my godding that's why Peter
Parker looked emo in spider-man three
why cuz he loves idea no because I'm
pretty sure like some sony exec was like
kid seemed to be into this emo thing now
and then gave Peter Parker a black suit
in a swoopy hair cut it made him brood
lightly
but he becomes like a zany dick and
that's part of the movie like yeah
because that was like that's my theory
Sam Raimi wanted to make Peter Parker is
a dick the studio is like the this the
nude seemed to be really into this emo
thing yeah can we give him an intense
swoop yeah maybe I still stand by that
part of it but I I've always very much
had a soft spot for for douchey
spider-man in part 3 or ease ya around
town snapping and pointing to do the
finger guns jumping and dancing and
stuff like that yeah I mean he's a total
dick to marriage and it's fun but
remember in high school when it was like
the shittiest thing you could be was emo
or middle school especially worse like
Oh everyone was making fun of emo kids
so I God sucks to be emo [ __ ] emo kid
and then it's like now now that we're in
our 20s there's like you know depression
is a very real very real illness and you
know it's like it affects a lot of
people and you know it's you gotta have
some sympathy for it it's like but
forget the emo kids were right yeah well
I mean in the emo kids were on the money
we were all making fun of the emo kids
but they got it well yeah that was a
time when when when just sort of like
things you were supposed to like and
hate just sort of fell out of the ether
because whoever said so because whatever
sort of nebulous version of your
microcosmic society said that's what to
do and so we all kind of hated email
without really knowing what it was and
just having like a vague visual cue
what's what's fascinating to me is like
I'm thinking of it now and I'm just
realizing of course there's kind of
taking it about face I still remember
like I still remember being like 12 or
13 when like [ __ ] was the worst thing you
could be called in school oh wow yeah
like you remember that right yeah and
now it's like yeah there's still like
very homophobic like you all knew it you
know yeah now they're like a homophobic
pockets of you know American
culture sure but you know it's like
legalized marriage and you know it's
like I feel like we're going to live
we're going to see the day when high
school kids just don't call each other
[ __ ] anymore that's just not a thing
that'd be awesome i'd be so happy yeah
unless i know there was an
anthropomorphic bundle of twigs and
class yeah like that's okay but ya know
or like people started getting really
into British slang smoking became cool
again yeah well god i was listening to
an interview just now um it's weird
because you know when I was coming up
not everybody but there was a good
concentration people who would use the
term gay [ __ ] rocks yeah and I was
leading to an interview on the way over
here actually in which um i was
listening to britt daniel from spoon
talk to marc maron which i guess kind of
a call back to the grab bag but um but
yeah he said like that sort of like the
cowboy guys go growing up in Texas like
they would call you queer [ __ ] oh and
this is like that weird instinct of
young love you know sort of children or
whatever to combine two bad things
without running real or two words
perceived bad without any real thought
it's like I pointed that out once as a
kid I was like what does that mean get
how could I be a gay [ __ ] does one negate
the other am I just back it straight
again or am I just like gay or the dump
is like a double negative yeah or is it
just like I'm so gay that I need like an
extra bit of gayness just to quantify
how I am like what's what are the rules
here and then and that's the worst thing
you do as a kid words like you at you
point out to it you point out to a kid
insulting you that is insult makes no
sense yeah and you're just not gonna win
that battle yeah cuz then they'll just
keep it's almost like some kind of
battering ram it's just like the no just
keep saying it yeah so why cuz you're
gay [ __ ] like no it doesn't make sense
why what does make sense to your gay
like you'll just end up in this loop
forever trying to trying to not be a gay
[ __ ] in a queer [ __ ] gay [ __ ] is a flat
circle yeah yeah he Maui it was one of
those things you know yeah that nobody
really understood but we hated it anyway
didn't you grow up and you're like
because I think sads a real thing
because like when you're 11 and 12 and
you're just like oh I'm starting to
develop pubic hair I have to be manly at
all times the way the scariest [ __ ]
thing to you is feelings yeah yeah cuz
people because people don't take too
kindly to sensitive types in the
schoolyard yeah I think that's it it's
like oh oh god I'm I'm I'm turning into
this freak that's not quite adult I need
to be manly and then it's like that
toxic masculinity thing is like that kid
is doing feelings kill him what it's
also like you don't recommend the
complexity seriously where you settle
the tug sad when you know there's more
to it and then nine times outta ten it's
like that kid is like what you said all
the time that kid like had a way [ __ ]
rougher life than you yeah it's like
what is sad all the time on my mom's
dead and my my dad has problems drinking
a lot and you and your cohorts are dicks
to me on the daily ya wanna be here I
don't want to be here i hate being here
everyone's miserable at home everyone
around me is miserable at school amen
would you gay you gay okay whatever
thanks [ __ ] nothing that we have
depression quests
I don't know it seems like a useful you
know perspective building tools nice if
if I can catch on with the youth yeah
little perspective doing a lot of good I
hate to say this but I'm kind of curious
as to what for instance for like I think
it'd be really [ __ ] interesting
because totally unrelated there's
another licky a small freeware indie
game called dysphoria where it's
basically like a series of little mini
games that you know are about a trans
women's transition oh man yeah that's
timely yeah I mean it's been around for
a few years and so I'm just thinking
what other like kind of often maligned
human experience could be represented in
a small game cuz I just imagine like
what racism quest would be like oh boy
looks like you're a person of color just
trying to live your life except racism
and your mom means well but she just
understood um I feel like I mean I could
be totally wrong but I feel like racism
is one of those things like your parents
can't probably wrap their heads around
it a little easier yeah yeah and then
the the generational differences will be
more subtle new and those things yeah
you'll you'll have more ground to stand
on together I guess because it's like
you you already have a foundational
likeness like depression you you know it
can run in families but like it's not
necessarily true that just because you
know what it's like to be depressed but
like your whole family will have that
experience to
no I think I really the sequel to
depression quest needs to be called
opression quest okay and you pick you
pick which marginalized which
marginalized bracket of person you want
and then you can stack them up oh [ __ ]
like your ear of black trans woman
welcome to opression quest ouch and then
we're gonna have like people
speedrunning it hey hey so you show on
the most effective answers yeah and then
it's like competitive oppression quest
it's like I'm beat I beat the black
trans woman level in under 15 minutes
now I'm gonna be an elderly Hispanic man
now I'm gonna be a gay do with bipolar
disorder type 2 now there'd be somebody
who's chubby oh man now I'm gonna be a
immigrant other quests oh boy yeah this
is a whole never-ending series of games
providing and then proactive and then
there's a secret mode and opression
quest where you're just a straight white
dude ahead as yeah as you mode because I
game yeah worse it's the easiest mode
because the worst thing that happens to
you is you get uncomfortable sometimes
there's there's like it's a four page
game you got trip on like one page no
too but you don't come on toast on
Facebook god it's not always about race
you guys no one challenges you yeah it's
like you'll you'll have at least two
pages where we're like you'll feel
generally awkward but only one page
where the decisions have anything to do
with that yeah and then you know you'll
pretty much win again it's like well
what can you do yeah you have absolutely
no trouble securing a housing no unless
it's in the power cedes yeah
Christ so Zoe Quinn make us oppression
question a compression quest because you
know after all that you've been through
the first thing you need to do is edify
us by make by you know making art about
feeling shitty hey man I mean sometimes
sometimes art that makes you feel shitty
is worthwhile no no no not not where you
want to go all the time but hey man its
perspective yeah hey now you're an all
star get your game on gets a boy fresh
inquests go play depression quest so I
don't know I like depression quest I
thought yeah it was actually I mean I
don't know fun is the word but I had fun
rolling through it because it's like
yeah this is this hits home and then in
kind of a you are not alone but not a
creepy alien kind of way we eyes
engrossing in the way things like you
know not not quite the same thing but
you know it's like it's the same way you
can have fun solving a math problem it's
like you're still attacking something
and engaging with it and sort of you
know turning it over in your hands and
sometimes that is fun in and of itself
just to engage you you know and and and
really dig through a problem no no so I
enjoyed it too yeah it's like it's not
like oh yeah woo but like you know is
interesting it's always interesting and
and seeing what the outcomes would be
like you start to get caught up in it
mmm so in the quest in the quest so for
all of you guys that have a that have
stuck with us um please by all means
leave a comment on your experience with
depression or depression quest yeah amen
this is a I would hope this could be
maybe you know a nice you know
benevolent space yeah you know totes
bonelves
bonelves Leonard bonelves now I can tell
it's late o'clock at night because that
was no you can do stupid things no one
looking for Leonard Brezhnev jokes at
this time of time so once again i am
aaron i am Jerry and and all you folks
out there stay sad a sank staying stay
dad no don't stay sad don't say sad you
can always work your way out of the sad
hole as we've demonstrated yeah apps may
be here to you gotta just click the
write sentences and and stay dank while
you're at it and stay doing kids stay
dang